this is sad face on your head just as
sushi was the stuff they have a little
day that just em the talk boy I'm
stepping away from that one
you know well those things are it's like
the movie her you know except with a
stuffed animal that that talks and has
artificial intelligence and that guess
we're alone my wife's are stuff that I
what you do to your wife is your baby
I got my stuffed animals oh my god is
that really how it does be yellow D low
d the dead fish its floaty the fish
that's beautiful over name of that it
was like a Syrian hold of them what are
you doing now we all have our animals
that's that stuff though yeah well you
haven't seen where I stuff it
we should pray talk about the episode
okay
dammit
we gotta keep okay alright sad face
alright so creative setup again just
like me like really creative this is an
episode where bball I forget the name
the lavender nectar nectar
growing robots
so next is beemo showing something off
says watch this happens once a month and
Jake's tail just to read
is out just throw it I see you over
there yeah okay whoa I'm sorry my bad
give them this stuff damn your sweat ooh
that is damn it okay
Jake's tail goes just like to sleep and
performs at a circus performs as a sad
clown and even though he never talks he
apparently has a job there they wait
once a month I suppose you know to
perform this show in the exact same spot
weird circus was a traveling circus but
it may only come around at one point in
time of the month and that's when he
joins up again I guess the circus
travels a lot I suppose that I need to
come around once a mom I mean yeah they
do the realms yeah so I thought circuses
were like they come once or twice a year
or something I know nothing about
certain sounds their fleas so they're
super tiny so they can't go as far so
you're also thinking about 24 hours for
us bugs in smaller creatures each time a
different way that we do I did not think
about that well done maybe a month to
them is a year anywho so so pretty much
you go sand performs and they have a
this chipmunk that also gets a lot of
people excited but she's unstable
because you know it's a chipmunking kept
at captivity we all know how they are
and breaks loose and starts eating a
bunch of the bugs but the tail convinces
her to let them go and the ringleader
pretty much says you have one chance to
make your show better if you do I'll let
the chipmunk go so he doesn't gets a lot
of money but they're still gonna keep
the chipmunk so he gets angry and
there's this big fight and he assists
the chipmunk free and there they're all
running out a lot of story short he 11
minute story short he escapes and goes
back to Jake's butt and they have no
idea what happened um BMO kind of does
but she's pretty much just staying
inside the tree like she they're just
looking
this tale extend out and then like they
have no idea what happens after that
it's like they just watch Jake continue
to sleep with this tale continuing to
extend so yeah I I thought this well I
dug it just for its strangeness and how
far they're going with the joke I like
it does sort of have this I thought very
silent movie feel to it there's a lot of
irises even the story is sort of like
the old melodramatic silent films I
think you can watch this with no sound
and get the idea even the tail doesn't
talk and I like the fact the tail
doesn't grow arms or legs right even
though somehow it can pick stuff off
like the whip and stuff but you know
it's Jake can turn to anything if she
can make his tail turn to anything so
there's something nice knowing that you
know he doesn't ever have it grow arms
or her feet or anything like that you
know it's very much like a snake and it
has no face except for the sad face so
yeah I mean it's it's pretty much kind
of going a long way for just this really
extended joke but it is still kind of a
nice story to the joke works because
they make it kind of this nice sweet
story and it really does seems like
something out of those old silent films
so yeah I thought yeah that was fun um
there's not much for me to say about it
I mean it was yeah really and truly you
don't want to drag her in your like
jewelry sure and it's like I want sort
of thing like is this really one that
demands a lot of attention for the deer
just a lot of deer joke and now we have
like three or four other of these things
yeah it's really cute and I like it and
they appreciate that for not having much
go on it was interesting from beginning
to end
he's probably do you he's so not
interested in what you're saying no he
doesn't care he's for someone that
demanded YouTube and as he just sort of
gives what in me here so he could go and
get more stuffed animals probably he has
a lot this is gonna turn to the ball pit
from - god that's twice I've made
totally dated these videos that I don't
care cuz - Todd is hilarious and it's
only like a few miles away cuz it's in
Schaumburg okay now a few miles but it
it's close how can I have a sad face on
if you're doing it oh my god that's
thank you oh my god is that it's like an
old gizmo originally oh my he was a
little boy this is like that was his
this is probably worse well worth
one of them hey still makes the
sound wow that Bendis will be worth even
more
so okay well the nice thing is the nice
thing is since I donated to - can we get
an extra hour in the stuff okay so go
ahead Jason your turn 100 needles yes or
a thousand needles depending I didn't
like it this is just totally
deteriorated and snuggle he's got his
mouth open so he's really creepy as he
say no when I first thought I was not a
huge fan probably because the whole oh
nothing's going on
but upon other watch things I actually
enjoyed it it was actually really cute
this these are actually Jason's these
are all Jason's to tell you are aware
and the deer is breeze we're a really
old house this might be where something
is hell now it looks like an Ewok but
wicked is in here oh here's another
gizmo here's Ruggie the reindeer I
remember Adi the reindeers of tanuki
damage oh and Pookie Yuri yes these are
awesome
here's wicked oh this this looks more
recent
yeah it's newer that's new it's a newer
guy but pooky-pook usin original flavor
like where'd you get those the one house
a while ago already together about ten
years okay you bought this once a day
every day so sorry I destroyed the
episode but it was still fun doing it
closing thoughts definitely different uh
the chipmunk reminded me of King Kong I
can kind of see that being shut off it's
like a prize and being chained up
there's an episode of Avatar where we
see what happened to the big bison Appa
Eddie's uses a service circus attraction
to remind me a lot of bad but I think a
lot of people do that where it's like
you know they're in the circus or
they're treated badly amazing you know
where those ooh or something that's
nothing new but it's again it's it felt
very much there like a classic silent
film kind of story
I like the father and son don't worry
this is all part of the Act you're glad
you came back yeah that was great
that's like Harry Potter sending his
kids dog words it's like there's just
some things I wouldn't put my kid
through yeah after going through it are
you actually organizing the stuffed
animals oh my god you are you're like I
thought that was ocbs really OCD and
like oh this one's sucking on my teeth
ah there's floaties mrs. Walker
she knows no cuz they're mine they'll
destroy your army of stuffed animals get
them my pretties i watch pokemon